لاربعة الاف ومائتي شخص. بعد ان
تراجع الروس قليلا نهاية العام
وذلك بحسب وكالة الانباء
المركزية الكورية. رئيس الوزراء
امتلاك اسلحة نووية سيظل واقعا
صارخا غير قابل للمحو الى الابد
عثمانية الى اكبر مكتبة في تركيا
تتضمن اكثر من مليوني كتاب وتتسع
ان الكرامة لا يوجد لها قطع
غيار؟ اردوغان يحول ثكنة عسكرية
العراقي يعلن تأييده بقاء القوات
الامريكية في العراق الى اجل غير
مسمى مبررا ذلك بمكافحة الارهاب
بحسب جورنال الات هذا؟ الا تعلم
والتطورات. بعد ان وصف الامين
العام للامم المتحدة انطونيو
قتل خلاله ثلاثة عشر جنديا
امريكيا جراء هجوم. لتتجه واشنطن
للقوات الامريكية من افغانستان
في عام الفين واحد وعشرين الذي
ومواد عن اوكرانيا وايران. خلال
ذلك غرمت محكمة امريكية مجموعة
النووية لانه خطر واضح وقائم على
العالم. ترد كوريا الشمالية ان
سابق تعود الى فترة تولي بايدن
منصب نائب الرئيس الامريكي باراك
جوتيرش في تصريحات اطلقها مؤخرا
برنامج بيونج يانج للاسلحة
اوباما. وافادت قناة سي ان ان
الوثائق ضمت مذكرات استخباراتية
المتحدة من الداخل حيث بدأ
المعسكر الجمهوري صاحب الاكثرية
بمثابة حصان طروادة. امريكا تقع
في ورطة. الضربات تتوالى على
البيت الابيض عثر عليها بمرآب
منزل عائلة الرئيس الامريكي
عن تفشي كورونا واصفة الوضع
بالخطير. هنا قلق اخر ولكنه
العالمية بهذه الخطوة وتدعو
الصين لتقديم مزيد من البيانات
امريكي هذه المرة وذلك بسبب
السيارة الصينية اوتو اكس التي
استدعت اعلان حالة الطوارئ من
قبل بعض المشرعين الامريكيين من
في مجلس النواب الامريكي تحقيقا
برلمانيا في الانسحاب الفوضوي
الخطوات المتسارعة التي باتت
تتخذها مؤخرا عبر الدفع بالاسلحة
الذكية روسيا تزج بالمقاتل
الواعد او الروبوت ماركر الى
تعبيره. فهل سيرسل الشركاء لكييف
اسلحتهم ويبقون بلا اسلحة هنا؟
نحو تحقيق اخر. وتظهر خمس وثائق
سرية جديدة ستتسبب في احراج
الامريكان وتتكاثر بشكل غير
مسبوق. لكن اليوم تعاني الولايات
بولاية ديلاوير الامريكية لتضاف
لوثائق اخرى كشف عنها في وقت
ترامب مليونا وستمائة الف دولار
بتهمة التهرب الضريبي. الاحداث
بفيروس كورونا سجلت خلال اخر
خمسة اسابيع. مضيفة ان البلاد
الحرب في اوكرانيا. ومن الرجل
الالي الى الغذاء البشري. حيث
بخلك يا حفيد جاندي اربع عشرة
دبابة فقط لترد السفارة الروسية
تستطيع التعرف على البصمات وخط
السير وتتصفح الانترنت وبها
امكانية تهديد الامن القومي
الامريكي. واعتبار هذه الصينية
بل افضل مما توقعته روسيا او ما
توقعه خصومها. ليأتي الرد من
تماني كاميرات. وهو تجسس من نوع
جديد في سابقة خطيرة وغير مسبوقة
بلاده اسقطت اكثر من عشرين
صاروخا ومؤكدا احتياج كييف
اوكرانيا تسير كما هو مخطط لها
موضحا ان الاقتصاد الروسي مستقر
للاسلحة الموجودة في مخازن
شركائه لوقف العدوان الروسي حد
الارهابيين الذين يقاتلون شعبه
بالصوار والطائرات مضيفا ان قوات
قتيلا وثلاثة وسبعين جريحا.
لتكشف اوكرانيا عن القدرات
العادة كشفت لجنة الصحة الصينية
ان قرابة ستين الف حالة وفاة
تعترف. بكين تصدر القلق للعالم
وللغرب خصوصا، ولكن وعلى غير
وافادت السلطات ان القصف الروسي
على مبنى سكني خلف ثلاثة وعشرين
للترمي بسهام الاتهام نحو موسكو
بارتكاب مجاعة في البلاد. الصين
عادت ازمة الحبوب الى الواجهة
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تتهم
تخطت ذروة الموجة الحالية اواخر
الشهر الماضي لترحب الصحة
اوكرانيا بالتخطيط لتفجير صوامع
الحبوب وافتعال ازمة عالمية
في بريطانيا. ان هذه الدبابات لن
تساعد الاوكرانيين في تغيير
الوضع على الارض بل ستصبح هدفا
مشروعا للقوات الروسية. وفي ظل
واعلن عن اعتزام حكومته تسليم
اربع عشرة من طراز ولاول مرة
واسلحة ثقيلة اخرى لاوكرانيا
خلال الاسابيع المقبلة. ها يا لا
ذلك اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانية
حالة التأهب الجوي في مقاطعة
التحتية. ليعلن الجيش الاوكراني
انه استهدف مواقع تواجد القوات
فاغنر اثناء محاولتهم التسلل الى
مواقع اوكرانية. لتؤكد نائبة
اتش تو دي تو قائلة ان وزنه طن
ولا يمكن اسقاطه. هناك خرج
التدميرية للصاروخ الذي دمر
المبنى السكني من طراز كروز كي
الاوكرانية تشير الى انها رصدت
نحو ستين غارة وتسعة وستين هجوما
هربا من الموت المحقق في
اوكرانيا. سكان كييف يحتمون داخل
انفاق المترو وسط هجوم صاروخي
روسي مكثف. وها هي هيئة الاركان
لضحايا كوفيد والصحة العالمية
الوضع خطير. وطريقة شيطانية
انه بوتين المجنون. لقد اسقط
علينا صاروخا بحمولة طن. هكذا
تتوقعون. وازمة الحبوب تعود الى
الصين تفصح عن العدد الحقيقي
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشيسوناك لبى نداء الزلنسكي
النظير الاوكراني زينونسكي الذي
قال مستغيثا انه لا يمكن وقف
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
قائلا ان العملية العسكرية في
للامم المتحدة. عليكم ان تتقبلوا
الواقع فليس امامكم غير والعراق
يبحث عن الامريكي مجددا. روسيا
تضرب بقوة. المعارك تحتدم والقصف
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان معارك
شرسة لا زال في سوليدار. خلال
صاروخيا شنتها روسيا على عدة
مواقع اوكرانية بما فيها البنية
تشتعل في الولايات المتحدة وبيض
في فوهة المدفع. كوريا الشمالية
يهطل من كل مكان واوكرانيا وحدها
هي من تتلقى كل تلك الضربات.
الروسية في منطقة سوليدار. وان
قواته استهدفت مقاتلين من قوات
صرخت اوكرانيا لتعلن حالة التأهب
والزلنسكي يستنجد. نحن نحتاج
وبوتين يرد. لا شيء مما
تتخيلونه. والوضع افضل بكثير مما
اليكم فلا تتركون سوناك يفي
بوعده للاوكرانيين لاول مرة.
يستخدمها الصينيون للتجسس على
امريكا وواشنطن تتدخل. التحقيقات
الماضي. عدا بوتين لتبدأ عودته
من سوليدار. فما هو التالي